Alright, this is our last one. This is our last draw. This is the employee gift, and it is, I believe, a Lululemon bag.
Ooh, I want one.
Alright, hopefully nobody claims this one.
I'll take it. Yellow and white. Yellow and white ticket, number 5791-2684.
Who's that to me? Oh, nice!
Nice! And what's the one? Congratulations!
Guys, all of these prizes will see Crystal in it.
Okay, so Crystal has all your prizes outside. Alright, so you can claim
your prizes from Crystal outside when you're ready to leave.
I hope at this point... Yeah, they have their own software.
Hey guys, wait up one sec. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hey guys, before I hand out the winners of our product
pitch. I just have to say thank you to each and every one of you for making the
trip out to Woodstock today. We love this event because it just gives us a really
cool opportunity to connect with you guys, talk some business, but more than
anything just really get to know you and you guys get a chance to know us. I have
to thank all of our vendors who made trips from all over the world in order
to be here to support our company, most importantly our country, which I
absolutely love. So thank you to everybody who made the trip up here. We
We will never be the 51st state.
Yay, Canada.
All right?
And, but most, I need, oh, God.
Our team here at Uvillage just did such a phenomenal job.
Guys, we start planning for this, like, tomorrow already.
For those who don't know, we already are planning for our expo in January.
It's here on the East Coast, January 31st.
So write that in your book right now.
We don't know the theme yet.
Don't.
I haven't nailed the location, but it will be somewhere close to here.
But that's January 31st.
our team works so incredibly hard to to organize events like this to decorate and put on great
uh great efforts in order to connect with you guys and show you guys new equipment and talk
about products and and help educate you so you can grow your business today especially was
incredibly hard between is it raining is it not we inside we out we pivoting we've getting a new
tent we still got great tents it was just an absolute uh just just non-stop pivot pivot pivot
at Pivot and the team. Everybody you see walking around in our glow shirts did a phenomenal,
phenomenal job. They all deserve a huge round of applause and a great appreciation and thanks for
me and everybody here. Just amazing, amazing, amazing job, guys. We love what we do, and we
do it for you, and this is exactly the reason why we're here. So thank you so much for coming. Thank
you, the UVLUX team, and certainly a thank you to all the vendors. As I wrap up, I want to invite
all of our pitch presenters up here for a second. Is everybody kind of still floating around up
here. The good news is is we're at Uvilux and we all love each other. I get two
microphones so I'm louder now. Everybody's a winner today guys so every
one of our pitch contests we're going home with something. First of all we have
our two runner-ups. One runner-up first goes to Daniela. Big round of applause to
Daniela. Certificate for the wall and for you. Our next runner-up in no
particular order goes to Nicole and Ashley. Great job guys. Thank you for all
your hard work and your effort. Our third place winner and winner of $200 goes to
Brooke. Brooke, where you at? Great job girl. Wonderful presentation. Brooke from Miami
Glow. Absolutely awesome. Second place and $350 goes to our best
dress couple Chelsea and Alex congratulations which makes our winner
miss Sherry Hawk Sherry where you at congratulations great job big hug thank
you thank you again everybody we will see you back in January please feel free
to come anytime you want to here we're an open shop and come and tan and hang
out and just be with us we love that otherwise we will see you in January
thanks again for being here today please drive safe and take care of yourselves and be well
all right love you all thanks so much okay bye